[Music]
Donald Trump announced he's gonna
moderate a Republican presidential
debate this is really happening and well
actually not just happening it's it
happened actually they shot the Trump
moderated debate yesterday and they're
not going to be airing it for a couple
of weeks we managed to get a hold of the
tape pretend that happen and when he may
take a look
sit down please know if you were me who
would you find I would say every person
at this table John has been very low-key
compared to the rest of you frankly very
much under the radar you know it's like
Casilla coasting along and you getting
by you too but urban is sort of quitting
it doesn't mean you wouldn't get fired
anyway it just seems to me you don't
feel that you can go forward that's the
job I understand what that means
you're a quitter and I hate quit so
urban you're fired
go everyone go
way to do it today